[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to another day
of game sports play for all we are
joined on today's charity stream by
Marcus parks from the last podcast on
the left hi Marcus hello good thank you
so much for joining us today we're gonna
be playing through some Dark Souls
mm-hmm and raising money for black lives
matter as well as Direct Relief so the
donation links on the screen you can see
bitter ly / GS - BLM to donate to black
lives matter and to donate to Direct
Relief it's bit bit ly / GS - kovat if
you donate will obviously read out your
donations on stream chatting through but
Marcus where are we in Dark Souls I
didn't I didn't even realize he was such
a big dog sauce fan actually Dark Souls
is by far my favorite game I mean it's
it's it's sir my top three games or if I
would say top four is yeah Dark Souls
number one followed by ocarina of time
Legend of Zelda then Mega Man 2 and
Castlevania Symphony of the Night nice
now I'm looking I made gigantic
Castlevania fan Wow oh love council I
mean the tattoo has different you know
meanings other than just my love Simon's
quest and Symphony tonight and all that
but I've seen the epic series I love it
is good right
it wasn't until I realized kind of what
they were doing until it got to the
point where you know they the fight with
Al you card you know like when I finally
realize like oh they're doing Symphony
of the Night and then when they started
playing like the orchestral version of
bloody tears like the song they are you
- that's unlike I mean I mean I love
this show this is so great this is
exactly what I wanted so I'm looking at
our chat and I felt like we should do
some excellent we should do the
introducing the two communities to each
other moment there's a mixture of like
games for people again like what's going
on and then there's like dogmeat mech
installations
I'll game
like Lucy and I are obviously huge fans
of the last podcast on the left when
Marcus is a co-host of and writer of and
also kind of one of the masterminds
behind the last podcast network and if
you're unfamiliar with los podcast
network or last podcast I'm left
specifically it's it's a true-crime
slash it's so much
I'll let Marcus explain it but yeah so
that's that's how we kind of got to this
situation like we loved the stuff that
Marcus Henry and Ben and various other
people do and we thought let's try and
get them another thing that you know we
we like and we can do and is gaming so
games about community meet the last
podcast community last podcast community
meet the game's web community you'll all
love each other please be nice yes so as
NACA
please behave yourselves I know you will
you're wonderful people go straight in
all of you as human beings so for people
for people who might not know what lost
podcast is about how would you describe
it because it's a weird thing to pitch
like it's a true-crime podcast but done
by basically comedians and the whole
point is kind of demystify these
criminals right and so how do you
explain it well it's the way I kind of
explain is as far as all the topics that
we go is anything that was covered on
unsolved mysteries will be covered on
last podcast you know it's it's true
crime it's aliens
it's cryptids it's you know ghosts
anything paranormal out-of-body
experiences all sorts of weird stuff but
yeah I mean it is I guess our bread and
butter over the years has been serial
killers like who just released a book
last book on the left that is it covers
nine serial killers you know throughout
history the nine biggest or most well
known serial killers out there but yeah
a lot of it is demystifying and
defanging
a lot of these serial killers because
what we realized like early on is when
we were getting into these heroes serial
killers and really like checking out
their lives and seeing who they really
were people we found that they were
losers
I think they are worms they were
pathetic in every way you know once we
really started getting into the details
of it because you know if you watch true
crime journalism documentaries movies
you know based on serial killers they
make serie codes out to be the
supernatural monsters these creatures
that you must be afraid of at all points
at all times you must have nightmares
and be afraid of them at every point
every time uh and we thought that wasn't
the case at all you know there there are
plenty of things to be afraid of in the
world trust me but serial killers are
not one of them right
that's a great way to know media wants
us to be afraid of yeah well what you
should be afraid of is the caping dragon
however yeah so like just before the
stream started Markus just absolutely
destroyed the gaping dragon oh I thought
I thought oh he's starting a boss fight
just before I was just gonna go down but
nailed it um so we are streaming for
charity links are on the screen what
we're gonna do is every time Marcus dies
we're each gonna donate five bucks and
thank you to our loads of Viacom CBS
they're gonna match that and if you
would like to join us in matching that
donation keeping track of how often
Marcus dies feel free to do so in the
comments will be reading the chat and if
you have questions for for Marcus please
check them in there I want to talk about
serial killers true crime Dark Souls
have a conversation this is the time
this is the time anything like that yeah
so I've just just defeated the gaping
dragon and I am now on my way to
Blighttown oh god I'm so thankfully I
mean I'm playing this this is the dark
souls remastered so Blighttown is
thankfully not the laggy mess that it
was on ps3
so it's not a it's an it it's still a
nightmare it's still an awful awful
nightmare but it's not it's not-- you no
longer have to deal with computer
glitches in addition to everything else
that's already in Blacktown yeah
justjust the poison dogs it's fine yeah
yeah it's not like that's no problem at
all
yeah so you mentioned that you've
actually completed dog shows a bunch of
times I think that's the one interesting
thing that kind of I love to hear when
when like podcasts that I listen to for
ages they just casually drop in oh yeah
I was just playing
Ben has started doing this a lot on the
podcast recently and he's just like yeah
I was playing battle for the other day
and you're like oh what been like more
recently a lot of podcast I listen to
her story to really just like slide in
video game references and so we I kind
of knew we knew that you played video
games but we didn't realize how big a
dog so it's fine oh you've competed
multiple times right yeah I mean well
I've been a video game
you know I've been a video game player
since I was like 5 years old when I
first got like a NES you know started
with you know of course like Mario
Brothers and Legend of Zelda and all
that I just pretty much never stopped
playing video games like all throughout
the years like I stopped for a little
bit in college then when I moved to New
York City like I bought a secondhand ps2
and got Shadow of the Colossus like now
I'll I'm back into video games like full
time then I got back got back into it
like Shadow of the Colossus and fallout
3 and all that and then got a ps3 and
then my friend
Holden McNeely who's also got a who's
got a show on the last podcast network
all blizzards and our game the game spot
people with absolute love because it's I
actually got to hold in yeah make some
stuff for us a couple years ago
and then but like it end up we took the
role in house but yeah I'm not holding
yeah you sent me a picture a little
while back and the actual subject matter
very quickly like burn out so it was
unfortunate but I've been meaning to try
and get him on something again soon yeah
you really should like he he's great i
Holden's the best like he's the one like
he does twitch streaming on the regular
but but Holden's I also always been like
a big video game guy and then like he
just told me it's like you've got to
play Dark Souls like you got to do it
alright fine I'll try it out and I
played it for I think about 60 hours and
I just got to this point like what takes
a few hours like I took like 60 hours
because I was just trying to figure it
out all on my own yeah you know I was
just trying to figure everything out and
not take any help or anything like that
and also figuring out the mechanics and
the gameplay and everything but I
finally I finally got it like I put it
down because the gaping dragon like
killed me like it just I could not
figure out how the hell to do it but
then after a few months I got picked it
back up I tried it again you're both
things get on my head but I finally like
picked it back up again and I it just
clicked
thank you like for some reason I don't
know why it click it just did and I know
probably the people the games but people
on the stream are probably screaming at
me right now that I'm going the wrong
way
Blighttown but it's very difficult to
play Dark Souls to hold a conversation
yeah yes we appreciate that it's also
kind of co-op benefit because we will be
yeah I thought I saw that Eric put on
the death countess and now it's the part
of the overlay so thank you for doing
that so I don't have to keep trying
yeah there was just something about it
just click like there's something about
like that the patience that it takes
like when you first start playing it
like it's somewhat like the patience
it's somewhat maddening but once I
really got to the point where I got what
to do and it became like a very like Zen
experience for me I trying to like kind
of the same thing over and over again
getting just a little bit better every
time like that's what I really
appreciate about this game is that like
it really it just it pays it like hard
work pays off yeah our work and
impatience and all that stuff at all
it all pays off in the end one thing
that I just discovered though is the
gaping dragon throat my sword
so yeah I was gonna say Dark Souls is a
game that like I think it in a weird way
despite the fact however much it beats
you down it instills a weird feeling of
confidence in you mm-hmm I don't think
any other game has ever given me as much
of a feeling of accomplishment as a
Souls or blood-borne
because it's so intimidating but then
you then you kind of do it and you kind
of work at it incrementally and then
it's like oh no like it's not actually
that intimidating really if you just
sort of play to the game's rules rather
than your own yeah and it's kind of like
it makes a lot of sense that you ended
up liking this game Marcus Prince I mean
as you said previously like some of your
favorite games are castlevania and mega
man and Mega Man especially like that's
the same kind of like uphill climb to
just get the smallest amount of row
right and a lot of this similar for
Castlevania as well simply of night and
Sam's questions like that never looked
difficulty and we were talking earlier
about you not playing you haven't liked
clicked with blood-borne as much yet but
I just remembered there's an area in
blood-borne which is the 3d Cosmo Vania
game does make you cry yeah yeah there's
a special hidden area in that game which
is incredible getting there but it's
called castle cainhurst and yeah is is
Castlevania they made a small cast
Aranea game with amplifon and it's
absolutely phenomenal yeah it's my
favorite part of that game
although master logarius was my least
favorite part of our game because I was
very-very underleveled for yeah so like
you you have to do a certain thing like
you need to basically find a summons to
this castle where a an ancient group of
vampires basically have been hidden away
and hiding and you get taken there by
like a in a carriage drawn by like a
ghost horses yeah I know and then when
you get there and you turn around of the
horses a dare didn't have yeah and then
you're like and then you're like in
Dracula's castle basically man and it's
incredible if that does if that doesn't
get you could give a blood-borne another
shot nothing will oh yeah I'm looking
for I mean I know like Last of Us 2
comes out this week
that's probably gonna take my attention
cuz I'm just now I'm just now finishing
up with Final Fantasy 7 oh yeah so I
need some I loved Final Fantasy 7 once I
got used to the combat and figured it
out I've never been big on like square e
square Enix games I got it I got it
it's good yeah yeah we have the voice
actress for Aerith on the charity stream
tomorrow yeah yeah I'm gonna be
interesting we're gonna be playing with
her but yeah for those watching please
do I know that we've got a bunch of the
last books in here please and while
you're here donate generously for the
causes were raising money for and one of
them being blacklivesmatter
that's a bit Oly for 30s - BLM and then
we're also raising money for coded
relief efforts which is better ly for
30s - Kovach I know the local community
is incredibly generous as as a member of
it and all of us like we've been around
that or we know how much how good and
warm the people are there so this is a
great opportunity to show the gaming
world how cool you guys are yeah we do
actually have a few donations if I if
I'm gonna read them out got some time so
Suarez Rao gives 25 dollars to bat last
massive thank you so much thank you Joe
Bradford $10 um Patrick Hanrahan $5 and
John days $25 thank you so much thank
you everyone thank you very much
everybody
you made it to Bligh town yeah yeah oh
and Patrick Hannah Hannah asks Marcus
what is your favorite wean song uh food
sabji very good means my favorite band
oh yeah I keep like wean is a band that
I me I know that I would like and I
really want to get into I love
transdermal celebration looks like the
one we know um that kind of keeps being
offered to me by Spotify but where do I
if I want to get into them where do I
start
start with that album with that one yeah
yeah what Quebec is such it's such a
great album and it's a really good
introduction of the ban chocolate and
cheese is also pretty good introduction
but it's you know they're more they're
90 stuff but if you like transdermal
celebration like the the album is more
of the same I could also and also white
pepper is very accessible because that's
the thing about ween is that there's
there's a lot that is inaccessible right
there's a lot of their music that's very
challenging but those any of those three
albums would be great
perfect thank you yeah it's like um I'm
a big fan of Beck and so some of his
stuff is like very you know you've got
odelay you've got sea change morning
phase they've been way more accessible
then you go something a bit more
left-field like midnight vulture
it's like how much do you like Prince
before I recommend this album to you I
love me I'll still like defend like
mellow gold as oh me too
like one foot in the grave I like one
foot in the grave okay like it's the
folk stuff is also yeah challenging yeah
yeah mellow gold is fantastic but it's
one of the best albums of that year what
is it 94 93 yeah bike then yeah
odelay 95 6 I think so yeah
and yeah man I remember midnight
vultures was 99 yeah so I remember that
came out when I was in high school
midnight vultures if you I always loved
asking people this question but it's
like if you could go back in time and
see any band any show any tour what
would it be and why I would go see the
Stooges right like I would yeah I would
absolutely go see the Stooges there's
this one show the Cincinnati Pop
Festival show that is its have you ever
seen the famous picture of Iggy Pop
walking on hands like he's walking like
he actually he's this it's this huge
crowds like a festival show and he walks
out into the audience and they're
holding up his feet and he's just
walking on like then oh yeah son hands
yeah and it's it's right it's right in
between I think it was it was right
before fun house came out so it's like
it's the Stooges at their absolute
height of power you know before the
drugs really took hold back when the
drugs are still like doing them good
before like all the whole drug stuff
came in yeah this the Stooges at their
height would be like that would be a
hundred percent the that would be and
that I would go see and possibly like
that show right there the funny thing
about that trick the walking on hands we
talked about this cuz me and my wife
also have
music history podcast open space a lot
of fans about in the chat - oh hell yeah
great but yeah um the Stooges series
Carolina told a story is that David
Bowie tried that same trick a couple of
months later oh no I'm out in the
audience but one there weren't enough
people in the audience and - David Bowie
realized how much core strength Iggy Pop
has yeah and how much core strength it
takes to keep yourself up all doing that
pose right just right onto the floor so
is doctor that's incredible
no I was gonna say all right you know
what would you what what is what is
yours mine is I feel like this is a
cheat because it is on DVD but the INXS
Wembley show from 91 oh yeah they are
remastering it in 4k and I watched that
video and I cried like I don't know why
INXS well I mean it was he the big band
for my family like we had a cat named
kick example I think I know that show or
the David Bowie you know let that last
show where he said Ziggy Stardust is
gone he's dead and everyone is just
because they didn't know what like the
fake-out was and then we're crying I
would like all like Nine Inch Nails so
good I don't know downward spiral yeah
but that meant goods like they're
incredible now I'd love to go see them
live okay watch I go see what's mean ah
yeah you move in like February or
something yeah it's weird we're supposed
to be going my roommates and I supposed
to be going to see like Weezer Green Day
and I think Fall Out Boy like it's just
revisit the early noughties and it
hasn't been cancelled and it's next
month
Tom what would you go see Dena
did you get oh you got got uh he was
right in front of me almost god I was so
careful you guys are about to get five
bucks I was gonna say I'm more of a
hip-hop rap guy so I don't know which
one there was there's like it there was
a deaf damn pouring Def Jam tour in 1987
which was like LL Cool J Eric be Houdini
Rakim like dougie fresh and Public Enemy
that could be like interesting but I
also really like West Coast rap so I
think in 2000 they had up in smoke which
was I think it was exhibit Nate Dogg
Warren G dogpound
mm Ice Cube Snoop Dogg Dre and like if
they did if I had the opportunity that I
would probably do that that's a that's a
big one for me I actually like I don't
want yeah I don't I don't go to like
live events very often like I I don't
like crowds and if I do go to crowds I
have to be like with people that I know
and really feel comfortable around like
the the one I went to a concert for a
rapper called immortal technique which
he came to London and it was a like a
small small like venue and I paid for a
ticket and I got there and I when I got
there there were so many people I think
heels like his first UK tour I got so
freaked out that I just immediately left
and went home cause I was like I can't
handle this yeah yeah I can't handle it
and like I there was another one where I
did actually stay PI like hid in a
corner and it was more it was for the
GZA of the wu-tang clan and of course
like I was hiding in a corner where I
felt like I was safe and obviously he
singled me out and like immediately came
over to me but like on the one hand I
was terrified
on the other hand like he he threw up
the W and I got to throw up the W with
him and I got a my like all-time
favorite good things well I went to a
Kendrick Lamar and when he came to
London recently for his damn for yeah I
went with one of our clothes for
Joe scrabbles who works at IGN and is
like a fan of podcast as well and me and
him were there and he was we me and him
which is like on cloud nine the entire
time I can reclaim all live is unreal so
yeah it's incredible awesome
all right boy that no go ahead go ahead
no no go ahead go ahead
oh no just good with you know flat
unfortunately the the workloads with
last podcast like I've had to miss so
many great concerts here in New York
just because we have Thursday and
Thursday like that's the day when like
last podcast scripts get written I was
written in that the night before every
week so yeah that's how I missed liars
missed the Damned you know so so many
great shows but we don't we have got to
see some pretty good ones over the years
like me and me and uh my wife Karolina
yeah we're big concert goers like we've
got to see it like Primus when you know
they did a big tour a couple years ago
we got to see them over the last few who
into belt a spill god speedy black
Emperor was amazing so we are we saw him
the Luciferian towers for him it was so
good and they were fantastic I'm sure
the last one last concert I think I went
to was nine inch dance but no I saw
Interpol at the Greek in 2018 and if
you've been to the Greek but that venue
is an open-air amphitheater and it is
incredible it's like the best place to
see bands over here and Interpol
like that's cried yeah it was so they
were so great I did I got to see them
on the boys I think it was 2003 like
that like on I guess it would be on the
antics for they were it was yeah it was
like it was all the Interpol you want
love yeah you know first two albums and
nothing but those first two hours yeah
they did that the bright lights tour as
well when they just played the album
start to finish I really wish had seen
that yeah but no the show that they did
they played rest my chemistry which is
my favorite although I think I think PDA
is my favorite favorite
antipas on what they did play rest my
chemistry yeah and I was getting a drink
at a time and I have to like a sprint
back second time I saw wean and they
started playing hey there fancy pants
just yeah it's always like they always
you always feel like okay this is the
safe time to go the toilet this is from
the new album I don't know this follow
it up with a banger yeah boys do a mom
quite impressed with your ability to
talk and play I would have died many
times by now I'm like really surprised
I'm like that we we're trying to get
money out of the guy and he's just doing
will I I'm just gonna yeah I'll get
money no matter what you don't have to
wait until I die to give money
ya know well I'm actually that's that
well that's the things that you know
here here at the house like a lot of
times me and my wife will like hang out
while I play video games like I'll play
video games you know we'll just hang out
so I got very used to talking and
playing Dark Souls we have a bunch of
donations so I'm gonna read these out so
for black lives matter which is bitter
ly / GS - BL em if you would like to
donate we're all gonna be donating every
time Marcus dies so far so far we're at
one he got you got sprung
about to happen again
so to have read out John days John days
$25 thank you so much Daniel carryin $25
thank you
Audra farmer all caps $25 thank you so
much David Cunningham five bucks thank
you
Eric wolf $25 David Cunningham $5 thank
you both
now eyes is it far I hope I pronounced
your name right ten dollars that's all
for black guys might say thank you so
much and then over to Kobe relief bit
dot ly / GS - bovid Sourav again they
donated for black for as much as well
they donated an extra 20 bucks
thank you thank you thank you thank you
that's their notes and once it because
this is blades I hope this is I think
this is workshop this has cut off on my
screen ten bucks to kovat relief Marcus
I love all the LPN shows what punk bands
would you recommend for someone who
loves the Ramones and the misfits I have
to think about that for a second hmm you
love the Ramones The Misfits I would say
the Damned welcome to I would say you
know like all of I would say the Damned
if you're into those two bands because I
just man I love to dance so much like it
was there with the datum just one of the
bands that I'd like before we really got
into it no ducks like I knew them pretty
well but I mostly just knew like the
first album and I knew that the first
album
very important to the you know the
history of honk which is that's that's
what we're doing on the first season of
no dogs is we're kind of doing like a
short history of like punk rock music
how we want to tell it you know
definitely not definitive
we're telling how we want to tell it and
you know the damn look we both really
love that first album but then once we
got into their full discography like
once we really started getting into that
machine gun etiquette and the Black
Album strawberries all that stuff like
it really were a highly underrated band
I don't know what is the damn much more
well-known in like do you guys know that
it cuz over here like the Damned like
you know they're it's not like they're
known by music nerds but I know anything
like that like you know Eloise was a
cute kid
in like 85 I don't know I think I just
kind of learned of them from osmosis
rather than like actively being into the
times but that might have also been like
the crowd that I was hanging out with
when I was like the pink punk new metal
yes teenage oh man I finally got a
couple of British people so I can
finally ask it was the guitarist of the
Damned and it was a gigantic hit in the
80s in our weird little song that's like
a cover from the musical South Pacific
oh wow
it was a huge hit a John Boyer was happy
talk what year was happy talk so we
might not know it looks like 1982 baby
might we might not know about it but I
think this is a pretty good measure for
how popular it was Lucy will immediately
react to this but it was featured on
show called Top of the Pops Oh in my
case that means it's big yeah that means
it's big yeah so yeah so like any any
song that makes it onto that show but
when it was around was a big deal yeah
that means that would have charted yeah
we'll try pre highly I might know if I
heard it that's how it sounds yeah
follow something from we happy few or
something sounds like something from
like Yellow Submarine so a lot of people
in the chat saying hi to Karolina I'm
working right now I'm doing great girl
I'm killing grave accent yes she's work
she's hard at work on the slits part two
right now awesome
yeah we're staying that they were
staying in the British bands for the
moment yeah it looks like you're doing
really well hair I mean it's uh it is
the blight time you know I'm it's the
black town and I also very rarely use a
halberd I usually yeah a sword guy so
I'm a little hmm
rusty with this usually I use the like a
crystal halberd it's like a boss killer
the one that you get in Anor Londo yeah
but yeah I'm not doing too bad with it
here yeah I'm interested in how much
like you obviously love dogs I was how
much did you dig into the fandom and the
creative process behind the game do you
know why is the way is no I really
haven't
this interesting like I think that's too
like obviously we're also huge Dark
Souls fans and it's kind of its kind of
odd jobs to take into the game and
figure it out and explore the cultural
impact and I think the thing that most
people who don't do that find
fascinating is why the story is the way
that it is like disjoint it broke
and kind of peas that you yeah and the
story actually is the way it is because
I'm sure games for audience will know
this but maybe the folks in the audience
or some of them know it's but you might
be news to them is the actual director
and writer of the game here doctor
Miyazaki he grew up pretty poor and he
didn't have a lot of entertainment so
his main form of entertainment
apology's like any of this wrong but his
main form of entertainment was reading
and he loved fantasy books and he loved
D&D a problem was a lot of it was
written in English and he wasn't great
at right understanding it he could
understand bits and pieces so what he
would do is take the bits he understood
and create a story in between to connect
it so the reason why the item
descriptions are the way they are and
they'd kind of allow you to fill in your
own story is because of that experience
he had growing up that's awesome yeah I
love how it's you know it's hard fantasy
where it doesn't explain anything like
yeah but by the time I'd like finish
this game and you know did the final
cutscene and all that I still had no
idea what the part of the game it's like
not whatsoever he's like I didn't even
know I did could even like lighting the
bonfire bleeding like no idea that's so
cool
you should there's there's like a
massive community that that has
basically
unpacked the entire story and it's
absolutely fascinating there's a guy on
YouTube who fans of the franchise well
no code is called party video and he has
a serious could prepare to cry where he
takes text stories from within the game
and kind of tells them in 10-minute
chunks and so like there are they are
like amazing stories that you probably
just don't even know are happening like
the story of solare he's just like seems
to be a main kind of like comic relief
character but it actually is incredibly
tragic and it's kind of like alluded to
him being this basically like a king
that has been of a kingdom that it's
kind of you know he's royalty
effectively but he gave it up to chase
this dream of pursuing sunlight and that
so if you want to learn about the story
there it's out prepared to cry is there
for you people shout outs a party yeah
everyone's like child about you
Suarez says what's the next band after
the slips the crafts yeah that's gonna
be yeah this led say yeah that's we've
got we do have it pretty much figured
out until the end but I I don't want to
give away too much but yeah well I'll
definitely get it it is the cramps after
the slits going back to New York and
this is gonna go to be gonna go to the
West Coast scene sounds like a series of
like symptoms for a bad illness but you
get the slits then you get the cramps
and then the West Coast Thank You
scorpion being a woman the raid Williams
says check out illusionary wall on
YouTube for his new Dark Souls behind
the scenes and unfinished stuff it is
amazing yeah recreated the fridge yeah
one of the one of the people that oh oh
here we go it's not the same place is it
no no yeah no it's the same place is
that a head of it but it's just slightly
ahead yeah illusionary wall is like
someone who digs into the coding and
finds the stuff that they cut and
reconstitutes it and reconstructs it
which is really impressive yeah this is
this is I see you're gonna be alright
yeah you never yeah there's the one
thing I learned about Dark Souls
never assume you're gonna be alright
never let your guard down always have
patience
sourabh up also asks do you like Fang
Marcos bang hmm I don't know thing me
neither
interesting let's have a look have a
look
Fang band is an American hardcore punk
band from the early East Bay punk rock
scene established in Berkeley California
in 1980
yeah hardcore uh I know the hardcore
kids are gonna be somewhat disappointed
to me but I just I don't know a lot of
hardcore hard words that's that has been
the genre of punk that we've had the
seraphs that at least I've had to learn
the most about apparently that's the
hard core so yeah I've had to learn the
most about parkour just because it's I
can't know everything according to the
legacy section and Wikipedia Fang has
gone on to influence an array of west
coast bands and has been instrumental in
the hardcore punk movement guitarist Tom
Flynn's distinct guitar playing has also
influenced many followers including the
grunge genre in Kurt Cobain's list of
his top 50 albums land shocked by Fang
was at number 6 interesting Robert McKee
asks Marcus how do you balance research
for last part and no dogs imagine that's
a lot of reading what it is but on no
dogs the I mean I know I've I definitely
want to make I've made this clear on the
show luck Karolina does the majority of
the research on no dogs she's [ __ ]
she she's brilliant with that you know
she does she does the majority of the
research and figuring everything out
like as far as timeline goes and all
that stuff and being she's up there
dharmaiah ain't gonna work
but yes she does the majority of the
research there and and also like we have
like research assistants that help us
out with you know a lot of like the
details and like figuring out exactly
you know wind shows happened who they
happened with and just getting the
timeline right because that's very
important to us it's like given time
right because rock when you're dealing
with stories involving musicians
especially punk musicians from the 70s
they don't have the most reliable
memories that you know when it just
comes to remember what happened when so
you know chair Lena goes in and like
there's a lot of great resources online
for you know like a lot of fliers fliers
help a lot and figuring out you know
where Captain sensible was you know when
you know they reported really I got a
lot of good alright yeah there's a lot
of yet there's a lot of research to be
done on both on both sides but you know
we've got we've got teams you know we've
got people helping us out with all this
because it's you know otherwise it would
be impossible for these shows to come
out every week you know it'd be
impossible or no dogs come out he'll be
impossible for last podcast to come out
of the week you know still be able to do
tours and write books and do the stream
all that stuff it is not it is
definitely not a one-person job yeah
he also does a ton of research for last
podcast as well Henry Henry reads just
as much as I do he he really gets to
know the characters because in order for
him to like that because it's the thing
about both know dogs and last podcast
like in order to be funny about
something you have to know it like you
have to really you have to know the
entire so you have to just you have to
know the world you know and you have to
know if we're all back and forth and if
you don't then it's just you're just not
going to get that but yeah the the yeah
you just you've got to know this stuff
backwards and forwards all right if you
don't it's just not you're just not
gonna be able to be snappy with it
you're not gonna know why to think
you're not gonna know why everything's
funny you know but you know Karolina and
Henry both do a great job like knowing
everything backwards and forwards and I
you know I just I need to know the story
well enough to write you know to write
to pretty much to tell what our
narrative is gonna be like what our
perspective on the whole thing is going
to be there's like mean Carolina work
real closely on what our perspective is
gonna be on no dogs I mean Henry work
together really closely on what our
perspective is going to be on last
podcast like all that stuff is planned
out ahead of time before before I start
writing and just to make sure
everybody's on the same page is it
easier if it's tough
I assume it's easier to cover cases from
America because you have that like the
background of a you know what you know
kind of the the sensitivities around in
America at that time whereas I guess if
you're covering people like Fred Andros
you are trying to
I don't know yeah glossed is a very
different place than yeah you have
learned a lot well we just had that with
our Peter Sutcliffe series where you
know we had you know you had to learn
about Bradford and you know yeah the
whole section where you invented the new
Yorkshire underwear was quite inspired
we won't recount what that is mainly
because my but you know listen to this
series if you want to find out what yeah
Yorkshire Underpants are but but yeah it
is it is a bit more of a challenge to
see like you know what is what is the
environment that these people operate at
because it's important to know you know
like it's important oh like what is the
environment that are operating in and
with with last podcast you know it with
America like it's a little easier like
safe we're covering like you know say
we're covering David Berkowitz like Son
of Sam
like I've I've lived in New York for you
know 14 years I know I know New York you
know like I don't necessarily know New
York 1977 but I know it well enough but
you know Yorkshire Bradford Leeds yeah
and very different 77 like I kind of
know the music scene in Manchester 1977
vaguely but I don't know you know all
the all the sociological stuff right all
the sociological stuff that makes the
story that makes the story interesting
you know it does require like a lot of
it does require just knowing I'm sure
but yet and learning a bunch of new [ __ ]
yeah questions from the chat so Brian
Reeves and pizza McGrath of both are
both asked that if there will be more
last podcast like video because
obviously do the streams but they're
asking if you think like a video version
of the podcast or any other
plugs well the things about the the
podcast is that you know last podcast
it's you know both podcasts are you know
edited podcasts so you know when we
record we just everyone throws
everything against the wall to see what
sticks like there's no I'll rat almost
like getting there it's very hard okay
yes uh we probably like it is like
they're they're edited shows like we
take our time with them like what what
you what people here on you know of what
the eventual the finished product is not
exactly what we record you know because
sometimes you know we'll try like I when
I'm writing a script or when I'm reading
my script like I'm not perfect in my I'm
not no I'm not I'm not perfect in you
know the way I read things so I'll shut
up Wow okay no this is that this is
about but you know like there's we don't
word also we're not all perfect when it
comes to my god oh wow what that no oh I
thought he was tethered he couldn't move
any further but he then just jumped
forward at you yep
yeah you go ahead friend all right there
we go maybe no oh man oh this is I'm
gonna go ahead and say this is gonna be
one biggest heartbreaks my whole career
this is a really rough life yeah you
just tell tab and I were like we do
actually have a bunch of a bunch of
donations too yeah I think that one
deserves a donation so who we got we've
got Sloane Wheatley gives $15 a black
matter thank you so much Shawn to me $25
to black lives matter
Thank You wolf Schneider 15 bucks thank
you and Madison cook $10 thank you so
much and yeah we'll be we'll be donating
along
I think donate a little extra for that
kind of spectacular death and pizza
McGrath donated $10 to covin relief
going to try and match the $5 per death
loving the crossover of GameSpot and
last podcast network Hale I'm gonna be
thinking about that death the rest of
today yeah for people who are new just
joining in a bit late we are raising
money for black lives matter and covert
relief efforts with Direct Relief you
can see the links on the screen
l y4 s GS - BLM and for black lives
matter and then bit ly for that GS -
covert or coded relief
if you are just joining in and wondering
what's going on we are joined by the man
the myth the legend the illustrious
Marcus Parks from last podcast network
and like us on the left and no dogs in
space and various other amazing things
accomplished writer now yeah
and we're playing dog shows for every
death we are gonna be donating $5
ourselves and up to three yes no I think
I mean we depth in my can hours that's
pretty good yeah really good so we've
got three deaths down but we'd also
encourage you guys watching to donate as
much as you can it's going to a good
cause
we've got two great communities coming
together here between the law and let's
be cool together and raise some money
yeah oh you oh no not the fraud no curse
frog so have you ever seen a picture of
that frog up close the basilisk no you
should google it because you see the big
eyes you see the big eyes on its head so
now those aren't actually eyes so if you
look at the actual image it's got really
tiny small eyes at the bottom that are
really cute and the big eyes are
basically a defense mechanism designed
to scare people it's really clever but
yeah it's actually quite cute when you
look at it up close it's got like a tiny
little beady eyes it's like don't look
at my face yeah don't tell anyone who I
live in a cute blast Georgie there's
also my other dog she always she usually
likes to sit next to me when I play game
and I woke her up from a nap oh yeah
wake me up when we get out of Blighttown
yeah I think like to make it through
this game you kind of need a cute cuddly
animal next to you the entire time so
one of the questions I was gonna ask is
and obviously you guys have a really
interesting dynamic
you do the shows and you are kind of
like treated as almost a kind of
professor you know everything and handle
Henry despite doing a ton of research
and being really smart it's also kind of
given the task of goofing off and
distracting people and the thing that I
love about it is the characters that he
does always catches you off-guard it
seems like and it like I love hearing
you guys laugh at the characters do you
remember do you remember which one like
really got to you in a big way either
made you laugh or broke you or for like
for me I know it's at least you can say
hurt but like the whole detective
popcorn experience was amazing for me
which I love and the hot dog squad so
those the ones that kind of like
crippled me and I remember because I was
working for London Underground at the
time so I was secretly listening to the
podcast like while working in the gates
and that was the one moment where I
almost got caught listening to podcast
because it broke me that one absolutely
yeah that that one definitely got me
like that guy because that was for me
like even that like character was kind
of a turning point in the show where it
was like okay they're like this is like
I think we really figured something out
with that you know like I'm doing a
character like him doing that character
and I was really big like okay there's
like a whole world with the serial
killer like even like investigations is
what what detective popcorn was they was
a character that Henry created based off
of the BTK episode the BTK killer Dennis
Rader that when you know BTK was a
serial killer that went free like he had
a reign of murderer that lasted about 30
years before you and the task force that
was you know formed to catch him was
called colloquially the hot dog squad
which is the dumbest name for a homicide
investigation squad that there's ever
been
in Henry created the detective popcorn
as like a member of the hot dog squad
I'm not gonna butcher it by like doing
the voice but he killed yeah so it's so
funny but the one the one that truly did
like break me where we had to stop
recording for a little bit so I could
compose myself was in the HH Holmes
series hmm minion nanny yeah does these
yeah I was like the very high-pitched
voice characters you know that we're
just it was just so Dom cuz cuz and it's
all just based on their names like it's
not based on them people like they were
you know just you know they were cared
like they were people who had fallen
victim to the HH Holmes you know back in
like 18:8 1890s that whatever the
struggle role arrows I can't quite
remember but just based off of the names
I can recreated these really high
pitched voice characters that I had to
actually like there was a full minute
when I kept trying to go with the script
and like continue reading it and I
couldn't stop laughing I kept cracking
up over and over again and I had to edit
out like two minutes of me trying to
compose myself like a minute of me
trying to compose myself and then
another minute of me starting to speak
and then laughing again and then being
annoyed at me like alright professional
there's already a couple of my mini I am
many in the child ready Lisa who is your
ferret oh yeah spring-heeled Jack I
still sometimes I'll leave a room and
shout no recording studio can hold me I
like this question this is from Robert
McGee in the choices Marcus for last pod
what are the hardest to research topics
my guess is the UFO episodes
so I don't think in terms of subject
matter like how difficult subject matter
I think which is just the least
well-documented
the least well document I mean when you
start getting into the history episodes
those are very difficult for me person
like history episodes that are just
difficult because I just wanna get right
you know like history's its Barrett like
I always want to get things right but
like history is like it's very important
for me to get to get the facts correct
so trying to make sure that everything
cuz especially like with something like
Rasputin like when we did that series
with characters like Rasputin especially
like someone because he's kind of
looking has become kind of a pop-culture
figure you know you don't know how much
is legend and how much is actual like
that you know but you just don't know
but so many times like legends cooler so
much more fun than you know just what
actually happens you kind of have to you
you have to sort of make a balance of
you know what when I'm what are we gonna
acknowledge here like where we got like
what are we gonna acknowledge us back
what's gonna go certain sometimes like
those legends will be like it'll change
the entire nature of the story you know
like it'll change that like if you find
something about Rasputin that is you
know it's like wow like it's finding
that [ __ ] out about him was something
that I you know I never knew you have to
resist the urge to be sensationalistic
you have to resist the urge to make the
story better and should change
essentially like change kind of this
kind of sort of change history you know
that's always that that's always the
challenge to not you know
just resist the urge that so many other
people think hey I don't even not even
go into the bonfire go for the souls in
the back too but alien episodes are
those those are also bad but those are
alien episodes are difficult for the
exact same reason you know because it's
like what what do you want to go with
like what what story do you want to tell
like because so many of these things
like can be debunked you know like they
can't be debunked through like you know
like well it could be you know the this
thing that they saw inside the sky it
could be this thing it could be that
thing it could be any number of things
it could be the reflection from you know
an Air Force Base two miles away or it
could be something really fun like it
could be a good or it might be that
skinwalker ranch is a paranormal hotspot
that actually holds the key to science
that we don't understand yet you know
Paranormal Activity science medoras yeah
it's a markridge could be the key or it
could be that you know this farmer this
Rancher decided to have some font or
this ranch you know somebody was losing
their mind or you know this or that or
what I could be any number of things but
it's you know it could but I also feel
the need to address those things you
know first to address the things in the
paranormal episodes you know the the
things that the things that it could be
and you know it's not always fun so okay
like it it does it sometimes it will
like necessarily kill kill what's going
on but it you know it sometimes puts a
bit of a damper on the whole thing and
like Henry's like do we have to talk
about that
we have to say that there was you know
this is that it's possibly a hoax Italy
yeah we do like we do cuz it also you
know because I know we have a lot of
skeptics that listen you know that and I
don't want to give them but but that's
the the problem with a lot of paranormal
stuff is that there is there is like
paranormal activity that can't be
explained
no but it's also very subtle it's very
small like it's not there's no you know
the Stay Puft it's what I just said in
the recent episode like the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man isn't gonna show up
that's not how it's gonna happen like
that's it well there won't it's a
paranormal research is a cumulative
process where it's built the case is
being built little by little by little
little tiny things here and there and
then there will be a big breakthrough
one day but it's not going to be
ghostbusters you know it's not good you
know ghosts aren't certainly start
showing up and eating hot dogs on Fifth
Avenue like it's gonna be very
scientific and somewhat boring and kind
of hard to explain I mean health you
have we have proved that UFOs exists you
know the government has admitted that
UFOs exist it's not even necessarily
that you know we don't we can't say that
they're aliens we can't prove that yet
but we know UFOs exist
they've been on cab and no one cares
but people care like there's a black
yeah I'm so happy that on a games both
streams yeah we know that you this is
this is what we'd be building TV we
managed to get a mind hunter coverage
going on-site we managed to get like
true crime podcasts this is mrs. a you
know like a revolution from the inside
out of tamanna we've got a couple of
donations
one of which is a good friend gab murphy
donators thank you he's also in the
chair he's also a fan of last podcast so
thank you for watching and then we've
got $25 from Matthew Gonzalez and thank
you for donating everyone you can see
the links on the screen bit go away for
such GS - BLM for black lives matter and
Bly Awards - yes I've been covered for
Kovach relief efforts Marcus I always
going to ask have you played the Mass
Effect franchise because whenever you
guys okay so like has have you
introduced those kind of aliens to Henry
because he's like seems to be the more
like alien focused person but I'd love
for him to like just witness a
conversation between like a Silurian and
a croakin and see what how it works in
his mind so what do L call yeah what do
you what do you make of the Mass Effect
franchise I mean I enjoyed it I liked it
it was just the for me like I I do love
I do love story like the story is great
in the Mass Effect games but number one
is always games like like if I'm gonna
like it I have to really love like fight
like that's why you know that's a big
reason why I love the dark souls game so
much it's because I love the gameplay so
much like that's it the look in the
gameplay and the gameplay on like the
massive that games you know I'm not uh
well this but it was you know I didn't
as I got in the back was cool but I also
I think I played them years after I was
supposed to play them you know yeah I
mean they've they've dated I think you I
mean especially the first game the
gameplay wise it's very weird to be you
know dead on someone to get a head shot
and then because got enough points in
that if oh no good funky it's very no
they were very clunky and I only played
them a few years ago so by the time I
got
to them like they were it was you know
it was dated definitely but Henry I'm
very proud of Henry he's also just now
getting into he just got a ps4 and he is
huge in outer worlds okay yeah yes and
the failure oh no death is death though
so five bucks all right for remember we
are we are the three of us are matching
donations five dollars per death so I
mean you can join in or you can donate
in advance but please try and give
generously if you can inspire soup says
I would love to see Henry romance some
aliens effect like I love the story was
so good but I yeah it's I mean isn't
there talk is there any talk of them
doing more Mass Effect games they're
real is that like I mean at this point I
don't know if it's wishful thinking but
there's a lot of rumors that they're
gonna remaster them and put them on here
for like my pie in the sky if they
remastered them all but with the
gameplay of three which i think was the
best in the series and like just put
them all on one disc i'd replay the crap
out of that I played Mass Effect 2 six
times I like exhausted that game and
time is the same so I I've had enough
separation from it now that I'm starting
I'm jonesing for it I'm like so I need
something to feel like void and I
believe it was like 2019 I think it was
the Bioware actually said they're not
done with Mass Effect and there are a
few things on the way so I imagine there
will be a new Mass Effect game in the
future a brand new entry as opposed to a
um a remaster they clearly could be
doing Dragon Age currently so the next
thing with Lee you want to risk five
more bucks here see if we do let me get
a good line-of-sight going here around
okay nice little sprint oh yeah Oh
Robert McGee says Marcus what are some
of the books you read for last pot last
pot and andö dogs that ended up being
surprisingly incredible I would um the
be in different stars above the book
that we use for our Donner Party series
oh that book was fantastic oh so good I
mean there was I mean Henry made the
joke in the series that like I wanted to
talk about like the manifest for the
wagons I did like I really he had to
stop me from like putting that in there
cuz it's just so fascinating and it
really it brings the world alive in such
a fantastic and readable way like the
world like that world of that world of
like frontiersman ship you know when
back when they had no real idea what was
inside of America like the interior of
America like they had some idea even you
know people you know there had been
explorers here for you know hundreds of
years and you know of course the Native
Americans had been here forever but they
the hubris of them going through all
like the hubris of them like ah well
like we like it we don't need to listen
to what everybody's saying we don't need
to listen to what everything what
everybody's telling us how we need to
leave early and how you know we we
waited too long yeah we'll take this
shortcut nobody knows anything about
this shortcut but you know what elephant
let's try it anyway let's roll the dice
with the lives of well over a hundred
people
and they were the the writer of that
book was able to really capture
everything that was both awful and good
about that time period another one that
really that was grades the was that open
up and bleed the Iggy Pop biography that
we use with the Stooges
really another thing that like we have
another book that really captures the
time and I was surprised like how like
my favorite part of the book that we
didn't really cover on the podcast was
Iggy Pop's career in the 80s buying all
that he went through then all the weird
things that happened with oh okay can I
offer this lad this is me and that guy
get that guy okay all right but yeah
that was also like Iggy Pop soldier in
the 80s but I mean there's so many great
books that I read throughout the years
it's really it's difficult for me to I
mean I've read so many hundreds of books
for the show this might like sound like
a stupid question but what is the mark
of a good book when you're doing
research like I do I imagine you come at
it from different angles right you
you're primarily you want to come out to
gain knowledge but you're also spending
hours upon hours upon hours you know
reading so do you prefer to have almost
kind of like a knowledge dump or would
you like it when authors are a little
more like flamboyant or try to create a
picture more interesting you know put
themselves there writing forward a bit
well I I feel like the two go
hand-in-hand
I feel like because the books that have
the information the books that like the
books that have the information like
they almost can't help unless you're -
unless it is a textbook the books have
the information like they can't help but
have a fullness to them
it's the books that try the books that
either that don't have the information
in order to make it a book they have to
create a they have to create the world
and a lot of them do that through awful
awful dialogue
I really hate books that's right I
really hate like historical and like any
sort of nonfiction book that tries to
put dialog into the book I can't stand
it okay you weren't there
you don't know what any public you don't
know what this person said or what that
person said like you have no clue and
it's misleading to try to pretend you
know and it colors it colors the
narrative completely unless it took like
a direct quote or something like there
should be no dialogue yeah like it's is
a hundred percent like storytelling and
you know we don't necessarily like I
don't know maybe I just took a cue from
you know other felt like the show that I
always took it like the biggest
inspiration for last podcast has always
been hard for history dan Karlin Sark
oysters which of y'all ever listen our
core history oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
phenomenal it's such a true is such a
true achievement but I can't even ever
come close to Dan Carlin because you
know that's the thing that Dan Carlin is
the
each episode each series like he spends
months yeah months on everything one I
have a key to it most to put all the
[ __ ] together you know to learn
everything and you know and because of
that sometimes you know we will always
admit when we're wrong but that's why
when people say that they like to quote
us in like college papers like don't do
that
don't like don't use this as a source I
guess like quote our opinions like
that's good that's totally fine yeah as
far as like knowledge goes never ever
depend on us you know it's the old thing
trusted their trust but verify it's what
you know that's what that's what we
always do and we did people do the same
for us speaking of trust but verify
have you heard of Paul Harrison oh my
god so we went to a show this is just
popped into my head when you said the
phrase Russell verify and we went to a
show with a serial killer expert we went
a week early hub and it was a comedy
night and we walked in and we just saw a
microphone and we said hi were here for
the serial killer talk and they looked
at us like we had walked in front of the
planet um yeah Harrison so we we went to
this kind of we ended up going and it
was really interesting he talked about
his kind of so he's a British profiler
and he's linked yes from Leeds
he kind of like had a lot of connections
and contact with various well-known
killers like um Peter Sutcliffe being
one among them he of mo'ne spoke to his
know his whole thing was that he was on
the Metropolitan he was
who the leads police force and he was
essentially some kind of exchange person
they sent him to Quantico yeah to work
with the behavioral science unit when
and they first got started he was saying
that like his very first in profile into
serial killers and the very first one
that he got to interview was John Wayne
Gacy so he had all this stuff all these
stories about we see about Manson about
it was clear it was incredible like
listening because he he and he was like
talking about the psychology part of it
and like he's super well-known he's like
a published author
I think he's got like 40 books and he's
been described as like the master of the
true crime genre so like they did an
interview with a bunch of FBI agents who
who are at Quantico during the same time
as Harrison being there and they were
like we have no idea who this guy is and
he like like publicly exposed as being
like from he went from being like one of
the most foremost experts on serial
killer psychology and like all the stuff
that they studied at Quantico to being
exposed as a 100% fraud no cuz I mean
this was back in 2019 all of his stuff
was pulled from shelves yeah I think he
did a shoo-in a Fuji am i right yeah he
did say he was sorry he said he was like
yeah I'm biased like you've made a
career for there you made money off of
it he described himself I was like we
can do yeah yeah like have you have you
ever encountered that kind of thing
where you like this person because you
read a lot you imagine you watch a lot
of videos from experts and has there
ever been anything that you like mmm
something off here no yeah I mean
there's there's with circulars like a
lot of times there are there are stories
there that seem like too good to be true
you know but you only see them like in
one place and there's no other
documentation like serial killers when
covering serial killers like that's the
number one trust but verify you know if
there's like here we go here we are
oh and they come it is the number one
like trust but verify source I can't say
that I can think of anything like in
particular then I like oh this person is
[ __ ]
but I do know that like like Katherine
Graham's 'ln who you know is a very very
well respected true crime author have
information and and she always seemed to
have information that I cannot confirm
like I can't find it anywhere else like
I just don't end up using a lot of her
stuff I have used her as a source but
like I used her as a source in the book
because she was able to like she ended
up getting a lot a pretty intense
BTK interviews and they ended up finding
out a lot about him but that was like
specifically from him but a lot of times
like it's it's always a challenge you
know to try to yeah let's take a little
breath on this latter question from
Derek McAuley says hey Marcus Ben
obviously plays the uninformed outside
of the for most topics but has there
ever been a time where his knowledge is
genuinely caught you off guard it
happens like we've been kind of joking
around lately of ugh you know like been
like oh wow like then you're really
getting into it like he actually is by
far his understanding of Matt
lately has been phenomenal like he's
getting it he's understanding like like
magical principles all that type he said
like he's actually like understanding
and getting it like it's and after so
many years of hearing me and let me just
pause for just a second oh yeah grab
that bonfire oh man oh oh
situation Oh in every way too close
yeah we're gonna get out of this one
okay but I yet but bins like knowledge
of what is it his his knowledge of magic
and magical principles has been very
surprising but not even his not even
like it's like he's become adept you
know like uh like understanding what the
hell is going on but that's been very
surprising it finally sunk in me and
Henry talking about chaos magic and all
that [ __ ] for so many years yeah I mean
like in the recent stuff it seems like
he's got better at making analogies
easier for people who can't mind
obviously he's great at that now I think
before he would just be like the joke
would be he'd make a mistake and
misinterpret it and you'd have to
correct it now it seems like he's coming
up with like really funny and kind of on
on point
analogies explain people that might not
get it which is an interesting evolution
in the Ben character Hawke he's
absolutely getting it
it's been interesting to do a couple
more donations yeah
okay so links are on screen right now
donate to blacklivesmatter bidder l GS -
BLM so got some through you'll have to
go back so don't get Murphy
Matthew Gonzales $25 Zachary Ryan $25
Chris Lynch $25 Pizza McGrath $10 I'm
Pizza McGrath $15 so I think he's
matching with the with the deaths as
time Marcus and I doing every time
Marcus dies we're gonna donate 5 bucks
our employer matches those so it's even
more money coming in and for kovin
relief bit dot ly / GS - Ovid
Jacob McCourt's for the games for
discord hi Jacob ten dollars keep up the
wonderful content Luci time and Marcus
haven't so week thank you mate
you too and Matt Hawking ten dollars and
no we've moved on from this a bit if
Gears of War can get an ex calm style
spin-off who do I have to talk to you to
get a Mass Effect tactics made EA mister
electronica art that would be really
cool I would I mean we talked about
already but I'm always up for more Mass
Effect so I mean I was as well until I
Andromeda happen but we'll see yeah what
was the deal with Andromeda I knew that
was I've always heard that was such a
disappointment to many people yeah it's
hard to explain what went wrong with it
but just the writing wasn't as strong
and I think it was a lot of like a
mechanical gameplay issues with it for
me it was incredibly buggy to the point
where there's good characters and the
good stories that were happening in
there were just really difficult to
enjoy and it was kind of also suffering
from being a new entry in the Mass
Effect franchise from a team that given
to make the originals so I felt like it
got kind of it was already in the
crosshair I like it's not as bad as
people
make it out to be like it's still worth
playing and it's just not as good if you
know there's still a lot in nights of
love
I just think them like there's also
extraneous factors like it was a brand
new engine that they had to work with it
and I just
it's obviously trickier to start the
story and like fill out all those
characters and it was such a big
departure but there's still some value
that if they do make another effective
feel like that teams probably got the
handle on it now but also it's dragon
ages turn so please also because the
literally the ending of Dragon Age
Inquisition the ending of the DLC which
is what 2015 now it's it's it's the work
playing and it is a lot better on PC I
think they patched it I remember I
played that game and for some reason I
went into like ways equivalent of a
dungeon and the game teleported my car
into the dungeon and I was like well I
can't ignore that and so like I
traversed this dungeon using a car just
bouncing from platform to platform and
it was just a ridiculous game but yeah
some of the characters were kind of
weird like Ryder as a character wasn't
as strong as Shepard and like the whole
new the new kind of races that they made
for the game like that went as
interesting they look kind of weird like
not really visually interesting and then
there was some great characters but I
feel like yeah they needed to spend a
little more time coming up with a little
more kind of like compelling a narrative
and also working at the kings of the
engine mm-hmm Matthew Hawking says I
thought the open world was a bit too
open and I didn't feel like enough to do
it would have been helped by a Titan
story like Mass Effect 2 or 3 hmm I'm
inclined to agree I think you always
kind of walk a final line when you go
open worlds like Gears of War had a the
latest one had a sort of mini open
section in the middle and it felt like
that's where it fell apart a little bit
but as soon as that narrative got back
on track and was bit tighter then it was
much more enjoyable you do know right
here by five deaths yeah well that five
yes something like that yeah that's I
think you're implied town as well which
it's a little easier given than you it
changes but it's still as we can see a
pain in the ass when these enemies get
you yeah well Peter McGrath in the chair
says can we just show Marcus some love
for his Dark Souls skills here he's
playing with an unfamiliar weapon and
killing it good work Peter you also like
dogs all three a lot right yeah Dark
Souls 3 is great like it it's a it
doesn't quite like I still love it it
doesn't have a no no there's a charm to
this Dark Souls that it doesn't quite
have but the gameplay is still great
I love the weapons I love the story what
little I can figure out but yeah I love
Dark Souls 3 the only one that I don't I
just can't do Dark Souls 2 it's the only
one I mean can't blame you to be honest
yeah that's erotic a rough game even
with the scholar it kind of reminds me
of like these the Dark Souls has like
that you know that 80's horror movie
charm to it and then Dark Souls 3 is
still got some of that but it feels like
a modern like reimagining or one of
those classic films like Invisible Man
from back in a day and Invisible Man now
like it still has some of the throws but
it's it's just a little more polished
and doesn't feel as like grungy so yeah
they're both great games but this is the
one you look it's great I've no see may
even think that yeah actually it's
really good
I've highly enjoyed it what are your
favorite horror movies or true crime
movies whatever it may be like what the
kind of stuff do you like to consume on
a day-to-day basis well on on a
day-to-day basis like I actually watch
stuff that like we're both huge Star
Trek fans here in the house
I'm more of a next-generation guy but my
my wife is a huge deep space 9 fan she
actually walked down by her request
walked down the aisle to the deep space
9 feet
Wow but the the quarks at 3 a.m. version
I mean yeah we have to approve because
Star Trek it's a fine Viacom CBS
probably supported
does that mean that I can't criticize
card oh you can if you want I mean we
have breakdowns from entertainment team
University in chesty and the folks who's
in the chat who's not good Yes Doctor
there you go Star Trek she's a fan but
like they do detail breakdowns and
criticisms of it so feel free to say
what you want no I mean it it was fine
it just it seemed like every episode
justice just as the action got going the
episode ended mmm like they were writing
it or like it was they were 45 minutes
long episodes that should have been an
hour you know right thank that that was
that was that's my only criticism
otherwise it was really fun and it's I I
but I'm also I got a beep honest I'm
tired of seeing old men run around like
I'm tired I'm tired of seeing old men
struggled their way through a seed you
know breathing hard and trying to not
die
I did feel about discovery then I have
watched a little bit I've only watched
like a little bit of Discovery like two
or three episodes but I stopped watching
it because I couldn't stand the
commercials
I haven't had cable in like ten years
and like trying to watch it like with
commercials like I mean I don't I can't
do this I
I watched season one and then the whole
took over Marc and even I was like I
don't care anymore my favorite
characters gone this character that I
don't understand or know much about but
for some reason I'm just weirdly in love
with was it there was a long period of
time where Tom and I be having a
conversation over slack or text or
something and then he would just end it
by sending me a picture of Tacoma Tacoma
my favorite thing about Tacoma is like
he's this Messiah character but like for
no apparent reason and everyone just
goes with it
like he's just like he's like the very
epitome of failing upwards in the Star
Trek universe Oh question from the chat
have any of you from Ben Barrett have
any of you guys played Jedi fallen order
it's kind of like Dark Souls but in Star
Wars yeah I know I I tried playing it
and then I stopped playing it and just
went to play Dark Souls because I thank
you so so it's like that the gameplay is
like so similar that it made me want to
play Dark Souls it was cool
I'm not deaf initely not gonna say it's
a bad game or you know like it was it
was cool without what I played a bit but
yeah yeah quite like on screen like
she's gonna guess he monetized
yeah oh yeah what what is it
banned from twitch yeah Jedi phone Nora
the problem is like that game is great
the problem is it's great the problem is
it also came up they also came out of
the sector oh yeah it's kind of like
call really after playing Secura or that
game is even even the best of games are
kind of like you look at poison and just
kind of wish but Marcus did you play
soccer I know we talked about
blood-borne I it was I need to give
sector oh another shot because yeah I
ran into the same thing that I ran to
with this game where it's I played it
for many many many hours and it just
made me so angry and I couldn't get the
parry down you know that's the entire
game I've been I am terrible at Harry's
in
every game that ever played it's just
there's for some reason there's
something about the time because even
like you can tell the way I play Dark
Souls like I play Dark Souls pretty much
tanking you know like I think the whole
time like it's it's defend and retreat
defend and retreat that's that is my oh
that is my strategy
so like secure oh and also like
blood-borne because like blood-borne
that I know I know how to play these
games like the strategy is attack like
the plot born it's like being aggressive
at all times and secure Oh like I know
once it clicks yeah it's one of those
games that I restarted I had to I played
the first six hours or so and then my
safe got corrupted yeah well no it was
because I was playing on my UK account
and then I played on my roommates
PlayStation which is American and it
region-locked my save so I felt like I
was struggling through it the first time
but then I went back and it's like
blood-borne it's like Souls when you
have that confidence and then you just
kind of blast through stuff and that's
how it clicked for me through trial and
through losing my damn safe I mean like
yeah I I reviewed the game and I put
into my review the fact that I got stuck
on a boss for so long that when I be the
boss I cried at the end of it and that's
kind of like the experience I feel like
once there's a moment where you fight
that specific boss where once you be in
him you feel like your eyes are open to
a different world like you understand
the game on a fundamental level now and
it becomes a different kind of
experience so yeah it is like most from
games where you got this a period of
uphill struggle followed by just amazing
gameplay for the rest of it so we're
okay which quail egg just earned a death
there so I think this is the part where
the our donations are about to skyrocket
we did we have had a couple more survey
has donated $15 to both black lives
matter and Direct Relief thank you so
much me and the comment on uh-huh
I'm Mathilde five pages just hello hello
he's a good friend of ours too we play
games with a lot back in the UK em a lot
of overwatch yeah but he would always
just summon us quite just sending us a
message
hello question mark and what do you mean
FA wants to play games every time we see
it now it warms our hearts yeah but yeah
if you would like to donate you can see
the links on screen is bit no ly /gs -
BLM for black lives matter and picked up
ly of course s yes - Col vid it's been
incredibly heartening to see the amount
of loss or cost fans in the GameSpot
chat and the games watch and chat folks
who are like oh I never thought we'd see
a lot of us crossover turns out we've
got a lot of LP fans just hidden in our
community there's a sign that you can
come and like share your love of the las
botas network with us we're here we love
it - if you can donate please dude
that's great - no I always like I love
the crossovers always like with like the
thing that we do it's the thing that we
do like crossed over was - no another
cool thing like that that always makes
me feel good like we get something right
now hmm
yeah we've had a couple people asking if
we played hell blades Enya was sacrifice
it's very like very cool it's gonna be a
second one yeah it's a very interesting
premise for a game so it's yeah it's
it's uses binaural audio it does have a
slight darksouls vibe yeah it's more
like an autumn ecology but the entire
game is about psychosis so and the
reason I mentioned the binaural audio
bit is because you play with headphones
and it kind of simulates the voices in
your head kind of it's it's about a
character struggling with herself and
and certain outside external factors on
this journey and it is a really really
impressive I don't want to say an
accurate representation of psychosis
because at the end of the case of day
it's a video game but the team behind it
when they brought in experts on
psychosis and people who have suffered
psychosis to advise and help them create
the most similar experience for people
playing it so it is a fascinating but
here's a fascinating melding of like
action game and mental health advocacy
Wow well worth checking out for that
yeah it's really cool the second games
coming out in the future but the first
one is really cheap it's maybe like six
or seven hours to play and it does have
Dark Souls ish by the in terms of
deliberate combat and a kind of
overbearing world that finds so what I
can I do
you doing okay here I like is not easy
now
Christopher Richardson in the chat so it
suggests putting the shield away and
double hand in that board yeah that bad
boy yeah
[Music]
risky business and office already said
it's a tank yeah play comfortably sword
always gets me as well you never know
she's basically spewing it
ooh Daniel Moreno asks do you see a
future where a Souls like it Minh v-up I
would love that but I've because then I
got a little bit I get the PlayStation
VR just yeah Resident Evil 7 wow I was
gonna ask did you try that oh my god one
of the most terrifying terrifying video
game experiences but like terrifying
experiences yeah I meant that like it's
just so immersive and they really what
they captured best like because I I grew
up in a small town Texas and small-town
Texas is filled with abandoned houses
just like the one that you know is
portrayed in that game like it's it's
Texas is like it's at least my part
Texas was just filled with abandoned
house because it was a dying like the
town with a gret the high school I
graduated from it doesn't even exist
anymore I can shut a few years after I
graduated and that was you know almost
20 years ago but it's so it was it was a
dying town so there's abandoned houses
all over the place and they nailed the
way those houses look in the way they
especially how they feel and I give them
kudos on that because that's that's what
makes that game so great it's not even
it's not even like the jump scares since
the jump scares are awesome it's the
environment yeah the environment is
spot-on perfect did you finish the game
yeah in viata coffee like three or four
hours no I I was hooked
and I I haven't really
I found like another VR game that's like
cooked me as as much as that one like
moss was really cool but it didn't like
the way like Resident Evil 7 just hooked
me so hard and I can't wait for that
because there's like the next one the
one on PS 5 is gonna be a direct sequel
right yeah it's a village so you still
still playing is Ethan but you got Chris
Redfield in the mix mm-hmm yeah they
haven't announced anything vr related
for a year obviously because there's no
indication of whether PlayStation VR
exists in the 4 PS 5 but I would I would
love to see that happen like I think
that did well for them
the OVR element - oh yeah so I bet you
they're exploring at least I'd be very
surprised to say oh my god oh no oh yeah
she's I took the the bloomin purple Moss
right to get rid of the poison status
right after I entered so she cornered me
immediately that was my fault
that's and that's what I love about Dark
Souls is that I immediately knew what I
did wrong I knew that it was my fault
nobody gets to blame with me fair chance
Cole asks um what do we all think is the
best Souls born game slash how would we
rank them I think time you're the only
one out of the three of us he's played
all of them cuz I haven't touched Demon
Souls or anything I barely touched dog
souls - yeah I'd say my ranking is
blood-borne dog shows one Demon Souls
Dark Souls no sorry blood-borne dog
shows one demon souls secured Oh Dark
Souls 3 Dark Souls - I think I say all
of them and then filled
Kingsfield yeah I would say blood one is
my faith
although I'm still just before the final
boss because I was I was playing it with
someone and then shelter-in-place
happened so literally right before the
final boss I just want I just might play
a new game but myself I do all the time
it's worth it let's do the chalice
dungeons Oh God
the Marcus you would say Dark Souls was
your favorite or three dark dark souls
ones definitely my favorite oh oh I do i
do love three and yeah like I do not
feel qualified necessarily to rank them
just because I it's not that I it's not
that I am notified it's that it's Sena
so that I don't enjoy it's not that
they're bad games or anything like that
it's just I'm not very good and if I'm
and that the things that like if I'm not
enjoying a game then I can I ask myself
like you know so it's a usually it gets
to like where I will give a game like
you know twenty thirty hours
again cuz both of those games like
definitely pulled me in enough where
like I gave 20 30 hours and then it's
you know a question of like heal after
that
am I so enjoying myself if the answer is
no then yeah I'll move on aside oh I've
been able to avoid those guys so far
but I would but as far as like the games
that like as far as I did play my I
would put blood-borne over over Sakura
this part might work that's fair um
skull sling a Dave suggests if you are
into your love crafty and focused games
Call of Cthulhu or the sunken city might
be good options I've like I sunken
cities been on my radar and I just I I'm
actually gonna go get my gaming PC from
the office today so I might just start
to download a bunch of um yeah I just
thought it'd son continue and I just
didn't get a chance to go back to it so
that's for one game I want it it's cuz
of the computer stuff I've been very
into Cthulhu since blood-borne so
desperate for anything that can evolve
even a small amount of that IO recent I
bought the kind of compilation in the
Necronomicon compilation of his work
which is both a because I wanted a ball
so he's a he's a noted wrong and tricky
very tricky
now because my feed is like just a hair
behind you so I get the reaction from
you - yeah I know
yeah that's what I'm playing here is a
little delayed so I'm trying not to
Telegraph my dad too much getting real
cocky when I looked up looked up at the
clock I was like oh man I got like 20
minutes left
Thank You plea lag that's a basic lag
when I'm using my main weapon all right
pretty the quail eggs pretty simple you
know when I got like a longsword you
know with the halberd it is a different
story altogether
I keep again the one thing I always
forget about it says it doesn't have a
teleporting system a fast travel system
until quite late in the game yeah so
it's yeah going back yeah I made I
definitely made a decision when I went
in the blight town it's been an
entertaining one yeah I made I made a
decision we'll see how it works out so
we've got 10 minutes roughly to see if
markers can be a quail egg but that also
means we've got 10 minutes left to
donate towards the fundraising efforts
that we've got and we're raising money
for black lives matter and you can see
the links on the screen Pitt Ohio for
SSDs - BLM and then bit dot ly for - yes
- covered for covered relief efforts
please try and donate if you can any
amount is beneficial and will have a
huge impact on the two causes that we
are raising money for please
pleased and obviously we are matching
fire we are donating $5 per death each
for mothers we up to 10 deaths for a
really good once I hit chaos wasted uh
scuffling a dave says marker see you
using the dragon shields he went to the
valley of the Drake's to pick it up yeah
I'm late in the drank a shield great
fire resistant Dave butthole fantastic
YouTube username is still stuck on the
Guardian 8 in Sakura and as yeah and has
not touched the game that's also where I
said because he's a that boss is a
blood-borne boss there's a couple of
bosses in the game where it's like you
we taught you how to forget how to play
pop on and play in a secure way and now
we want to make you play in a
blood-borne weygand just to mix it up a
bit and that's how they kind of keep you
on your toes there's another boss called
the demon of hatred in that in that game
which genuinely took me about ten hours
because it was so difficult you told me
that and I there's a point where you can
kind of walk Yemen field and I just went
no no he's very cookie but like I I
wasn't using any guides or anything like
that and eventually figured out this
certain items you can use to make it
significantly easier they're there in
front of you the clues are all there
just wasn't thinking straight
but I got there eventually classic souls
oh I got it no I'm gonna I'm sorry I
don't know we I mean I have oh yeah
honestly if I can play blood boy or if I
can play Dark Souls for two hours on
blyton and that's the first time I drop
an f-bomb I think I've done pretty yeah
guys pretty good yeah I mean that's what
this game is made for if you're not
dropping their spawn the game is
probably not doing this job well I call
everyone a [ __ ] I get that's my also
like my new my new thing is swearing is
like I just say bastards but like in a
very northern accent we play a lot we
play a lot of over and I just caught
everyone a bastard are you like I'll
make sure and beam when I do it mocks
are you into multiplayer gaming well I'm
not for me
video gaming is that's part of why I
love like Dark Souls like fallout 3 and
Fallout New Vegas is for me Gaming is a
solitary experience like I for me it is
an it is it always has been but it's
like especially I guess important now
with the job you know doing all the
awful research it's an escape you know
like it is like pure escapism like going
into the world leaving this one behind
completely and with multiplayer games I
am acutely aware of the world you know
other people and video games is a you
know apart from you know of my wife
hanging out next to me it's a total and
complete escape from
other people ooh
Pete's McGrath's has just donated
another $20 any chance of a Heil me from
Marcus
I passed my college exams today he'll
yourself hey Elliot self PA
congratulations don't eat me - hell yeah
he'll yourself you did it all on your
own yeah alright there we go there we
don't go Albert is a it's not the one
what else you got
yeah I was it well I was thinking I got
I've killed the dark spirit down here so
I got the butcher knife but my strength
I don't have the necessary strength or
the necessary decks hmm no broken
straight sword hilt
mail breaker I've got a bunch of heavies
I wonder if this yeah maybe the ex might
be slight damage drop but might give you
a little more control of the
maneuverability yeah just maybe yeah
yeah the doctors conundrum this is this
is classic dog shows oh I'm stuck
between a rock and a hard place
and I got nowhere to go and also many
people are watching me on a stream so
we've got like five minutes left but
before we go we should probably tease
that we actually we are actually
bringing you back for a stream next week
yeah so Marcus is gonna be joined by
Henry Zebrowski also of lost podcast
Fame and we're gonna be playing a game
that will put to test your ability to
deduce who's lying and who isn't so it
should be interesting it should be I
hope enry is better at these games and
I'm terrible so the game we picked is
actually kind of goofy as well so at the
very least you can make fun of the
accents because we know that and we're
gonna have that on next week keep an eye
on the games for channels on Twitter on
site as a schedule there but we'll have
both Marcus and Henry the idea was you
guys have spent many years looking into
serial killers liars and dishonest
people and you have this kind of
essentially they're the training of a
investigator so let's put it to the test
in a scripted scenario and see what will
happen
so we'll have some fun with that
yeah okay great yeah so yeah but he's
probably gonna be better at those games
than I am yeah played judgment I didn't
finish it but yeah this is so bad and
triangles like which statement and which
statement is a lie I always like the
telltale games
oh I always end up with like the worst
possible scenario le noir to but I think
Eleanor was okay but every time the
characters would lie there we go I just
I'm look off to the side really
obviously yeah so for the last podcast
fans that are in the chat if you're
enjoying the game in crossover but you
can get more of it next week so that
makes for Wednesday I believe so yeah
anything double check but that's I think
that's right
that's the 20 the 24 is here yeah we
wait the Thursday recording session for
you guys yes yeah so and then we've got
a couple more donations one from FA
Norfolk Ben Perry says praise the gain
good luck guys for kovat relief and then
we've got one from andrea Bodom sorry my
voice broke there cuz I'm getting
emotional
I really really hate way like Andrea
bottom donated $15 thank you so much hmm
we're gonna we're gonna let Marcus take
one more crack at my leg
yeah and then see how we do from there
hopefully it ends in victory
oh I'll be on here for another 20
minutes fatal dream rate so it's huge
less podcast gentlemen of the round
table fan awesome thank you very much
round table was the old day
all right we believe in there we go here
we go I've never used the Morningstar
before so I think you probably want to
swing a lot less like yeah really lean
into the hit and run strategy
all right there we go
start with the bar
Oh No oh yeah mm-hmm
you're thinking about it
it was a great room I think it does very
good roads no wait this one I hate that
one
okay there we go attempt was made yeah
yeah oh let's do are you so that's
that's what like $70 from us I'm
terrible Maps each yeah sure yeah that's
and then we'll get ours matched
obviously thank you so much for coming
on Marcus I'll let Lucy carry the stream
out but just want to say thank you so
much for coming on and see you again
next week
yeah much for uh for having me and for
coming out to our show in London like
way way way back when
supporters for a very long time so we
very much we very much appreciate it you
know there's been a lot of people done
with us for many years known yeah tell
are great so thanks for thanks for
sticking with us for sure and thank you
again from me and from the chat thank
you for joining us where can people find
you in the in the week until you're back
on GameSpot uh we are you can find our
podcast on Spotify just type in last
podcast on the Left no dogs in space our
music history podcast is available
wherever podcasts are available our book
the last book on the left is available
wherever books are sold
we're now in the UK we do a adults for
Adult Swim stream every Tuesday night
from 8:00 to 9:00 p.m. actually yeah
we're doing it tonight where we show
YouTube videos and just talk about on me
yep it's just a hangout so it's good
yeah if you need company we're there for
you yes before we head out just huge
shout out to the last podcast community
that joined us in the chat and have been
really nice and welcoming and warm we
expected as much but it's just been
great to see our two communities the
communities where part have come
together and just be super chill and
nice about it yeah that's great thanks
and thank you to everybody excuse me
thank you to everybody who donated to
the causes we very much okay and if you
want to join us for some more play for
all streams this week have
Briona white the voice of Erath from
final fantasy 7 joining us tomorrow
we've got Jake Baldino from game ranks
and Joe Zija from Fire Emblem three
houses it's a lot to say in there this
week alone keep an eye on GameSpot for
the full schedule Marcus we're back with
Henry Zebrowski next Wednesday
like we said thank you all so much for
joining us today we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]